[Music]
there's this same-sex couple from New
Zealand named Kat and Taryn and they've
been together for a couple years now and
two ladies two ladies same-sex guys
could've been two dudes no but then I
okay true can't tell you that we do okay
that's right okay it could have been
kaathal what those were the longer names
we just call me Carol anyway movin up so
Kat and Taryn they have been dating for
a couple years and they wanted to have a
baby together and that's when they
looked into getting a sperm donor and
they knew that they wanted to have an
agent maybe know so what it took me as
like it's they want they knew they
wanted to have a Asian baby oh I don't
know that I don't know that information
but probably so they because they're
both trying right they decided that they
will try until one of them gets pregnant
and then it stops like a game cuz you
don't know right oh my god right
oh wait let me go back a little bit so
they found a sperm donor on line because
the fertility clinic won it would take a
really long time so they found one and
then they got some like insemination
tools or whatever and him dude jacked
off into a cup and then we bought the
cup now she one girl got the straw an
inch they got the coming with an ending
put it on the donor oh well maybe he
looked at his poor father like he's
pretty tall you know he might be a guy
he's harvard-educated I didn't know you
could like just buy sperm like that you
could buy anything online now maybe his
profile cells so they'd just be like
cleared
maybe his profile says cells come on the
side that's a hard thing to ask someone
what for this part can I have her come
it's pretty easy dude I'm pretty sure a
lot of guys will give up their comm yeah
it is but I think from the other part
goon is it like legal [ __ ] for sure you
would need a contact yeah it'd be like
I'll give you my sperm but I want
nothing at the livery Parliament it's so
easy just in a styrofoam box with ice
cubes I knew a
from back in the bay there was a gay
couple and then they had so she asked
her brother so it be still related you
know that you get a random sperm and
it's not related to the pig
so she know her brother had sex with her
girlfriend and kind of pregnant wait he
had sex sex did he just do this with the
inseminations
maybe they wanted all organic baby you
just had it easier it just wasn't
awesome like these are my people
so not their white dough so why hurt
they just it was easier to do like that
he jacked off and he got really close
and he stuck it in last second so they
didn't like have too much no passion I
mean might as well yeah add a little bit
of passion okay so oral was off-limits
or do you think they did it music oh
sorry baby
we have underage here I love that they
can't see the cats are just sounded like
there would have been cool T pity and
then Joe just told I'm sorry baby
[Laughter]
underage kid in here we have to be good
anyway one of the girls so Taryn went in
first and back in February and that was
kind of like a trial run and to like
like see how all the cool process
happens and it didn't work so then two
weeks after Taryn tried that's when Kat
went in and then everything went well
and then she had to in seven nations
during that cycle and in two weeks later
that's when Taryn tried but then they
found out that cat was pregnant and then
a week later to that date they find out
that she was pregnant
yeah are you waiting to babies I guess
they were that's pretty awesome so
they're gonna be double pregnancies yes
they're gonna fight so hard I'm gonna be
pregnant at the same time I know I was
thinking about that I'm like how does
both pregnant they're both gonna be
fighting over resources what do you take
care of me no you think I mean and
they've all throw enough cuz it's the
morning sickness it's like you're drunk
because one person take care
ain't that crazy you made it seem like
it was crazy [ __ ] oh you made it seem
like you really need my help there are
those countries we're like the the
pregnant lady help each other and stay
together which country is this I've no
idea I remember seeing isn't it like
Sweden or some [ __ ] like one of those
Scandinavian it feels better going
through with someone like they are they
all live like in a [ __ ] hut not a hut
I'm just kidding but they have like a
facility yeah they all live at IKEA
Sumerian like some other countries where
like if there's like in the family and
stuff they would like stick around each
other and help each other yeah that's
only makes sense that twice nice to have
a big family but then it sucks when all
of them have something to say about just
want the help I don't want the comment
yeah I know everyone got something to
say about your career your life and all
that [ __ ] but they'll help out with the
baby I'm down I'll take yeah they're
both pregnant that's awesome I wish you
could have been pregnant you know it's
crazy to I wish not to out of one by one
that picture looks like a Siamese twin
[Laughter]
that's awesome and then they're hoping
that they give birth kind of close but
not too close because they want the
babies to have the same sleeping
schedule so it's like almost like having
twins that's so cute man so maybe like a
week or two apart right about three
weeks
I don't yeah double mutters yeah you
never know they could come early totally
when if they give like if they'd burst
the babies around the same time they
should mix up the babies so you don't
know which ones which so then you don't
have too much of a connection with one
you know you're not like oh that one's
my kid but that's all that only works if
they're born like back-to-back like the
same day or some [ __ ] I mean like the
part that's a high chance right no
because I love it obviously right that
means that their birth scheduled maybe
is like a week apart that what you're
saying is the mom doesn't get to see the
kid at all until the second one's born
hi damn hide him away
not gonna work man they need a tinted
they only share one birthday after
mm-hmm no that won't work
I will claw my way to my child oh
there's no way you're hiding them from
me well then you don't take this plan
let them have my plan it wouldn't be the
hour to hide a vehicle there's no way
you would give it give me the baby back
like if I met my kid and then you give
me another like I could tell my kid from
do you want to take my plan they can
take my plan either they won't and I'm
telling you okay that's it it's a book a
remarkable story but that's why I just
kind of pump the brakes a little you
know they kind of wanted it cuz it's
like okay truly true maybe because you
want a space that I love them water
which is like okay we're gonna
inseminate you okay cool just to double
our chances to make sure happen maybe
they were meeting their window like they
look older too maybe they were like [ __ ]
what if you can't have kids anymore I
can't have it let's just let's just hit
it hard possibility I don't think that
when they both got friends are like holy
Sh how do you think they got pregnant
just saw the Internet turkey baster we
do like same sperm donor - so both kids
are gonna be biologically really it's
all cool cuz I want to know what the
home kit is for self pregnancy I don't
think it's a home kit yeah cuz they said
the way she worded it is I went in
believe it like oh yeah the home kit so
that's what I heard - yeah I thought you
said it was really good that they got
the way she worded it was tried to use
the insemination tools and what tools to
use but she does say I went in first
like I don't know I don't know I've been
they fertilize the egg and then they put
it back I believe that's the way oh yeah
through like IVF but like just doesn't
sound like IVF dude that sounds like
cream pie hey I found a guy on Facebook
yo yeah cuz it was a two-year waiting
list for a sperm donor at a fertility
yeah I feel like if you go to fertility
clinics you have to use their resources
yeah they were racing against time
sounds like they're saying that their
doctor said that they were more likely
to win the lottery than to both fall
pregnant at the same time hard to get
pregnant huh on average it takes you
about six months of trying Wow so you
could [ __ ] for six months straight
and still not get pregnant let's not try
that though what you'd wanna have sex
for six more like random random
teenagers watching this no we could just
have sex for like six months yeah I mean
do it no no I say go do it but let me
tell you your life is [ __ ] over it's
over the kid is like taking it off they
even suck the energy and youth out of
you
they do look at me it's over for like
the first decade we've got your life
back took ten years and after that it
relaxed hell yeah I mean well it feel
like you're about to enter another storm
that's the thing it's a different kind
of stress we're like teenagers dressed
so all of it sucks is what you're saying
pretty much but I've met some moms at
our pediatric clinic and then the mom
was telling me like honestly the hardest
part is the beginning it's like later on
they do get all emo and they kind of
don't want to be around you and all that
but he was like what you can just go
okay go to your room close the door
that's a different kind of thing because
because it is like dressing they don't
watch him for now he could die you know
you run into somebody jump on the pool
you do whatever you have to keep your
eyes on it yeah right so it's like more
physically exhausting when they're
younger but when they're older is more
mentally and emotionally exhausted than
cages you should try it I mean if it's
colorful it'll be cute let me call and
playpens oh all right that's a cake I
like it in cages better kids in the cage
you should sleep in oh my god I'm just
the Ken cage huh yeah don't sell it to
Hispanic families there's gonna be a
whole problem that's true that's true to
to to to wheel to wheel but if I made it
like rainbow colors like the bar no more
blue green I think it would change nope
didn't there's like a little merry go
around inside it's too real guys it's
look if we keep to Rio you can tell them
what it's like at the kitty look at him
he's cute you know what'll work guys
yeah what'll work let's make a fire
perimeter around the kids don't never go
through it because we're already like
fires danger the kids not gonna walk
kids like that there's only two natural
fears I guess it's uh falling and then I
feel what the other one was right fire
it was a fire those two you're born
you're only born with two natural fears
all clouds and fire I'm pretty sure I
just made a loud noise they would cry
say look at you I believe one is falling
and then is one more well what can you
do where you can take a break and
there's a perimeter around the child and
it's safe well the only time I could do
that is when you're falling and loud
sounds so they have to learn to be
scared of fire everything else hot so we
all have that if you didn't burn a
finger or something and then you're
running cold water and your mom's
yelling at you all that [ __ ] you're
crying like a [ __ ] you never had
a childhood yep like already about it
really like I told you right yeah like
you were there yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]